>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Karen Lloyd: Good afternoon.
And welcome to the most
building in Washington, DC.
I want to thank you for
choosing to be here today,
to learn about some
incredible organizations
that are supporting
veterans as they transition
from military service.
I'm Karen Lloyd, a retired Army
aviation colonel and Director
of the Veterans History Project.
It is an honor to be
here today to moderate
such an amazing panel.
The Veterans History
Project currently has
over 108,000 collections
that span from World War I
to the current conflicts.
We are proud that the majority
of our collections span
from private to captain where
I would suggest the real
stories exist.
We need all the stories,
so others will understand
the sacrifice our veterans
have made.
Some of the veterans in
the VHP collection served
but never were deployed
overseas.
Many went to war but
never saw combat.
Others saw combat from a
variety of vantage points,
at the tip of the sphere,
on a PT boat, in a cockpit,
or at a headquarters, and others
paid the ultimate sacrifice.
But the veterans we want
to focus on today are those
who return from service
with a lasting reminder
of their sacrifice.
These brave men and women gave
their sight, their hearing,
their mobility, and many
other aspects of their lives
that we take for granted
and returned to a society
that was not designed
for their new normal.
The VA and other government
services are unable
to provide everything they
require, so out of necessity,
nonprofit organizations
have emerged
to make sure these heroes
have the support they need
to move on with their lives.
Our partner in this event,
Homes for our Troops,
is one of those organizations.
Homes for our Troops builds
and donates specially
modified houses
for severely injured veterans
so that they can live the
lives they did before they were
injured, taking care
of their family
and their home with
undue hardship.
Our expert panelists represent
not only homes for our troops
but several other
organizations dedicated
to helping injured vets adjust
to a world where accessibility
and accommodation are all
too often an afterthought,
if it exists at all.
The Elizabeth Dole Foundation,
Hiring Our Heroes, and the VA,
all work tirelessly to ensure
our veterans have the tools
and resources they need.
Today, we will speak about how
injured veterans and identify
and access these resources.
Our veterans have sacrificed so
much to keep our country safe.
Helping them live a more normal
life is the absolute least
that we can do for them.
My goal is that this event
inspires everyone within earshot
to start thinking about what
they can do for the veterans
in their community and a call
to action to get involved
with efforts like the ones
you'll hear about today.
So let's take a minute
to meet our panelists
and hear a little
bit about them.
First, we have Eric Eversole,
president, Hiring Our Heroes,
a program of the U.S. Chamber
of Commerce Foundation.
Eric.
>> Eric Eversole: Thank you.
Eric Eversole, president
of Hiring Our Heroes.
I'm also a currently
serving Navy Reserve officer
in the JAG Corps.
I have been doing
that for 23 years.
Hiring Our Heroes was and
organization that was created
by the U.S. Chamber of
Commerce back in 2011.
We were seeing a nationwide
crisis of veteran unemployment.
We had tens if not
hundreds of thousands
of service members coming back,
post 9/11 service members
coming back to a very,
very tough employment situation.
In fact, by 2011, for that
post 9/11 veteran population,
unemployment was over 11
percent, and so the Chamber,
utilizing all of it's state
and local, state Chambers
of Commerce, starting hosting
hiring events throughout
the country.
In the first three years, we
did nearly 800 hiring events,
and since that time,
we've done over 1100.
As we've worked to really reduce
veteran unemployment as a whole,
we knew that there were
still significant populations
of service members and
their family members
that continued to struggle.
So as the employment rate has
dropped, we've started to look
at those target populations
transitioning service members,
military spouses,
caregivers, wounded, ill,
and injured service members to
make sure that we can continue
to help them find the meaningful
employment opportunities they
so richly deserve.
>> Karen Lloyd: Thank
you very much.
Steve Schwab is the
executive director
of the Elizabeth
Dole Foundation.
Steve.
>> Steven Schwab:
Thank you, Karen.
It's an honor to be
here this afternoon.
The Elizabeth Dole Foundation
was established in 2010
out of a really profound
personal experience by my boss,
Senator Elizabeth Dole,
who if you know anything
about Elizabeth Dole has had an
unbelievable 40-plus-year public
service record.
But something that a lot
of people don't know is
that she has tirelessly,
lovingly acted as her husband,
Bob's veteran caregiver.
At 95, he's doing well
today, better than he was
at 94 actually, but he's had
his medical ups and downs,
and in 2010, after serving
nearly a year at Walter Reed
at his side, she came to know
the plight, the stresses,
the anxieties, and the
burdens frankly that a lot
of caregivers, military spouses,
mother's, fathers, siblings
and other loved ones
were shouldering to care
for their wounded warriors
once they leave the hospital.
And so we established
the foundation in 2010.
We started by doing
evidence-based research
with Rand, and that study
told us that there's five
and a half million military
and veteran caregivers
across America, and these folks
are experiencing depression,
immune deficiency
issues, cardiac issues,
all because of the hours that
they're putting in in addition
to raising their families,
trying to hold down a job,
while taking care of
their loved one at home.
Tomorrow is September 11,
and it's been 17 years
since the longest period of
war in U.S. history started,
and we as a nation are still
learning what it means,
what it truly means to take
care of those who have gone
to war since that time.
And one of the biggest
phenomenons that we've realized
as a country is how many of
these veterans need to be cared
for in their home and how
it's transformed the needs
of families and caregivers
in the community frankly
and certainly the VA and how we
need to treat, train, prepare,
and care for veterans and
their loved ones at home.
And so that's what we focus
on at the Dole Foundation.
>> Karen Lloyd: Wow,
thanks Steve.
Next, Brigadier General Tom
Landwermeyer, President and CEO
of Homes for Our Troops.
Tom.
>> Tom Landwermeyer:
Thanks Karen.
So I had the distinct honor and
privilege to serve for 33 years
in our nation's army and served
with distinct pleasure with some
of the folks inside this room.
And then for almost two
years now have been working
with Homes for Our Troops.
Our mission, as Karen
actually said pretty well,
so she could almost be
one of our ambassadors,
but we build specially adapted
custom homes across the country,
and then donate them to the
most severely injured post 9/11
veterans to enable them
to rebuild their lives.
So, our mission, even though
we're a national 501C3,
we really see our mission as the
moral obligation of our country
to pay back in very
small part a huge debt
that can never be completely
repaid to the troops
and their families that
they raise their right hand,
they volunteer, and they
serve very selflessly,
and they sacrifice
tremendously for the freedoms
that we're allowed to
enjoy every single day.
We've built 261 of these
homes in 42 states so far.
The homes themselves are
about, they're on about an acre
of ground, about 2700 square
feet, four bedroom, two bath,
with 40 plus special
adaptations inside.
They're really built
for a two-fold reason.
One, to allow that veteran
to regain some of the freedom
and independence that they
lost when they were injured,
and also, from the
spouse and caregiver side,
to reduce the stress and
the burden on our spouses
and caregivers and let them get
on with rebuilding
their lives as well.
There's a few things that are
unique to our organization
when you start looking
at others in our space.
One, the veterans tell us
where they'd like to live.
We go out, find the land,
bounce it off our veterans
to make sure that's
what they want.
Then we buy it and build them
a home from the ground up.
Second is three years of
financial planning assistance
that we provide all
of our veterans
and their families pro
bono to ensure they're set
up for success as a homeowner.
And then third, a real extremely
unique one is that we stay
in touch with our veterans
after we give them the keys.
So we don't just put a
number up on the chalkboard,
we've got another home done.
We stay in touch with them.
One, we want to make
sure that the quality
of the home is as we promised.
If there's something wrong
with it, we're going to fix it.
Second, we need feedback on
those special adaptations
that we put into the home
to make sure they're working
for the veterans
and the families.
Back in Taunton, Massachusetts,
at our headquarters,
we can't tell if they're
the right adaptations,
but the families living in
them day in and day out can.
And then third, really
what's important
to us is the rebuilding
lives aspect.
We want to know how
they're getting
on with rebuilding their lives.
>> Karen Lloyd: So
glad you're here today.
Next, we have Sergeant Curry
and his lovely wife, Sam,
American heroes to the core.
You take my breath away.
I want to thank you for
coming today to be a part.
>> Steven Curry: Thanks Karen.
So I'm Army Sergeant
Steven Curry.
I served five years in the
Army as an infantryman,
deployed to Afghanistan
and Iraq.
My last deployment I was
injured by a roadside bomb,
which resulted in the amputation
of my left leg below the knee.
The reason I'm here today is
in 2016 I was provided a home
by Homes for Our Troops, and
it's really helped my well-being
and my family's over the past
almost two and a half years,
just getting back into
a normal way of life
and rebuilding our
lives and just helped me
out physically as well.
>> Karen Lloyd: Sam,
a few words?
>> Samantha Curry: I'm Samantha.
I am the caregiver
spouse of Steven.
I will definitely say
that the last couple
of years has been amazing
because of the house
that we were given.
It definitely has opened
up lots of doors for myself
and our girls and even
Steven most recently.
Yeah.
>> Karen Lloyd: Great.
Thank you.
And last but not least, Jason
Beardsley, who's an advisor
to the Veterans Affairs
security.
Jason.
>> Jason Beardsley: So
I'm Jason Beardsley.
I spend about 22 years in the
military, both in the Navy
and the Army and had
the pleasure to serve
in our special operations
community and see a lot
of the work that gets done
on the forward edge
of the battlefield.
I came over to the department
of veterans affairs this summer
to represent our veterans
service organizations and in
that role represent
them on behalf
of the secretary of the VA.
And part of that is doing
exactly what I think most
of you have laid out here in
the panel, and it's humbling
to be here, one with heroes,
fellow service members.
Thank you, all of you.
But also to hear about the way
you're each really servicing the
veterans past their experience.
And it's one of the
most important things,
and of course that's
what we do in the VA.
We're tasked with taking
that service member
and closing the loop between
their service and then the rest
of their career,
their life's career.
And I think somebody
said it best here,
but finding that next mission,
and sometimes that's very
difficult and very challenging
because of what they've
seen in the battlefield.
So, from hiring to building
homes to being the veteran
that actually found that
next mission and has turned
around as a caregiver
to teach others
and train others is exactly
what the VA supports.
We can't do all the work
ourselves, and so we rely
on our community and
caregivers to help us with that.
Very honored to be here.
>> Karen Lloyd: Well, thank
you, Jason, very much,
and thank you all
for being here.
And so now that you've
met the panelists,
let's start the discussion.
So Eric, your organization
focuses
on veterans transitioning
to the civilian workforce.
What should veterans know
about this transition,
and what are the resources
available to help equip veterans
with transferrable skills?
>> Eric Eversole:
That's a great question,
and I think it's a question
that quite honestly has evolved
since the time we started
doing our back in 2011.
You know, as I mentioned
earlier, in 2011, you know,
veteran unemployment was
such a national crisis.
We were really doing
triage at that time.
I mean we were just trying
to find jobs for veterans,
get them back into
the workforce.
In many instances, it wasn't
necessarily the right job
or the best job.
It was simply a job so that
they could start, you know,
building that confidence and
finding those opportunities.
But as we've really
started to shift our focus,
we really started to
think about, you know,
who is that customer
set, who is that veteran
and military spouse
population that we serve.
And quite honestly, why
is this transition process
so challenging.
And what we found was
a lot of organizations,
and I think for a while
we were included in that,
a lot of organizations took
the field of dreams approach.
You just build it,
and they would come.
And all the problems
would be solved, right.
And we would just them jobs,
and we'd have somebody create
these 80, 90, 120,000 jobs,
and people would
just flock to them.
And that didn't happen.
It didn't happen because
what we forgot is that a lot
of our young men
and women who served
and their family
members are still coming
from predominantly blue collar,
low and middle income families.
They're not the lowest
10 percent,
so it's not that they're,
you know, really destitute,
but they're good, hardworking
middle class families,
predominantly coming from
the South and the Midwest,
predominantly, and
the Southwest.
And the reality is, is
that this population,
including their family members,
don't know what they don't know
about real economic
opportunity in this country.
What does the 21st
Century career look like.
And oftentimes, you know,
their perception on industry
and opportunity was
what they saw on TV.
So if you ask them about
transportation industry,
it's like Smokey and the
bandit, that's their image,
is bar fights and, you know,
outrunning the law
with bootleg liquor.
You know, manufacturing was
like Laverne and Shirley,
and these industries and
these opportunities don't look
anything like what they
did 30 or 40 years ago.
Go visit a Toyota manufacturing
facility that is so clean
and so technologically advanced
you can eat off the floor.
And you start to look at,
you know, transportation and,
you know, what these
opportunities look like.
So, one thing I would say
about what we've learned about,
you know, from the
outside is you really have
to help these young men and
women who have sacrificed
so much understand what
real economic opportunity,
what the American
dream looks like.
And if they can start to figure
that out, then they can start
to figure out what are the
skills and the certifications
that they need so that
they can really grasp ahold
of those opportunities,
not a year after they
leave military service,
because that's what we found
a lot of them we're doing.
They would, you know, I
mean we did a study on this,
nearly half of them would
spend four more months
after leaving the
service unemployed.
>> Karen Lloyd: Okay, wow.
>> Eric Eversole:
They'd take the first job
that they could find,
and they would,
half of them would leave
it within the first year.
>> Karen Lloyd: Okay.
>> Eric Eversole: And so we've
really started to focus on,
you know, understanding,
creating partnerships
with organizations.
There's a lot of great companies
doing some incredible work,
providing service
members with credentials
and certifications
before they leave.
Microsoft has this great
software and services academy
that are providing
I think 90 percent
of their graduates
are graduating
and getting jobs paying $90,000
a year within the first year.
We have a corporate
fellowship program
where we take the active duty
service members right before
they get out, pair
them with a company.
About 90 percent of our
fellows are getting hired
for about $90,000 a year.
And importantly, they're staying
in that job for more
than a year.
So, I think overall, you
know, we can't just assume
that if we just create jobs that
they're going to flock to them.
We have to take the time
to understand how do we help
train them and help lead them
so that they can continue
to serve our country
in a slightly different uniform.
>> Karen Lloyd: Yeah.
One of the making sures
of lessons learned.
Thank you for sharing.
>> Eric Eversole: Thanks.
>> Karen Lloyd: Steve.
You mentioned the Rand,
the 2014 Rand report,
and what was significant from
my perspective that it said
that military caregivers are the
best chance a wounded warrior
has to thrive had recover.
What makes caregivers
so important,
and what is being
done to include them
in the entire treatment process?
>> Steven Schwab: Thanks
for that question, Karen.
You know, I'll step
back a little bit
and suggest a big part of the
work that we've undertaken
as a foundation is to educate
Americans, educate clinicians
and leaders at the VA,
policy makers, and citizens
across the country that
this population exists,
that Sam has brothers and
sisters across America
who are struggling to care for
their wounded warriors at home.
And so the study
that we did pointed
out an alarming statistic, that
there's millions of these folks
in every corner of
the country, right.
And so we had to bridge a
cultural competency divide,
which we've been working on
for the last number of years,
to bring leaders in the VA,
all of our policy makers,
and mayors across the
country up to speed
that there were another set
of needs beyond the needs
of the veteran [inaudible]
right.
And so the study said
as well, the headline
that you just highlighted,
which is that statistically
and scientifically that the most
direct way to improve the health
of the veteran is by
strengthening training,
educating an fortifying
that caregiver.
So if Sam is strong
in her beautiful home,
outfitted for the kinds
of needs that they have
as a unique family, they're
going to be a stronger family.
Right. So, when we finished
analyzing the study,
we learned that one
of the big gaps
that was happening inside
the system, the VA system,
was that caregivers were
not being integrated
into the medical team.
And it varied center by
center how the caregivers were
being integrated.
So we started a new program
funded by USAA to train doctors,
nurses, and social workers on
how to integrate caregivers
into the medical team.
And so, it's called the
Campaign for Inclusive Care.
We're working across
the VA system right now
to train clinicians and
social workers primarily how
for the first time really
to bring those caregivers
in from day one and how we
make caregivers an active part
of the care process.
I mentioned earlier that
services and support
for veterans are largely
moving toward the home.
The VA is moving
really, really quickly
through an initiative
called Choose Home
to really shift the paradigm
for care from those institutions
that are based in every
region across the country
to remote care in the home.
And so we're working
really closely with the VA
on developing innovative ways
that families can receive
those services and support
without even leaving the home,
which allows folks like you guys
to get care easier without
having to travel, you know,
hundreds of miles, hundreds
of miles to do that.
>> Karen Lloyd: Wow,
that's amazing.
You mentioned that your
study had identified a gap,
and that gap was that the
organizations didn't understand
that across the U.S. there
were all of these caregivers.
Are there things that the
Elizabeth Dole Foundation is
doing to cause those
caregivers to have opportunities
to learn from each other?
>> Steven Schwab: Absolutely.
Thanks for that question.
There are essentially nine areas
where there are significant gaps
in support as a result
of the study
and folks have probably
heard, you know,
many of these mental health
support, care and support
at home, which I just
mentioned, employment
and workplace support,
which Eric's organization
really is leading the way
on and many others.
And so what we've done, and I'd
say the most important effort
we've undertaken of late is
something called the Hidden
Heroes Communities Program.
We're working with mayors
and community leaders
in 120 communities
across the country.
We were just in Minneapolis last
week launching their initiative
to work with those local
leaders and to make assessments
on the ground in communities
like Minneapolis and San Diego,
and these are communities
large and small in every corner
of the country, to see
what kinds of services
and support exists
for caregivers.
How we might integrate
caregivers
into for instance programs
that might be exclusively
for veterans and then
work with the community
to teach those organizations
and stakeholders how
to support the veteran but
also how to support the family.
I think one of the
most important things
that I've learned as an
organizational leader
in the veteran space based in
DC is that there's a big divide
between what happens here inside
the beltway and what happens
out across America where
people desperately need help
and support.
So this program allows us
to translate all the progress
we're making here in DC
from a policy and impact
perspective directly
on the ground in
communities with organizations
who are making an impact on
that family so that families
like theirs can benefit
in real time.
And so we're teaching
communities essentially how
to step back and assess and
care for the needs not just
of the veterans but of their
caregivers and families as well.
>> Karen Lloyd: I love
that holistic approach.
Thank you.
Tom--
>> Tom Landwermeyer: Yes, ma'am.
>> Karen Lloyd: There are 3.8
million veterans in the U.S.
with a service-connected
disability.
How does Home for
Our Troops select
which veterans will
receive new adapted home
and which veterans
are eligible to apply.
>> Tom Landwermeyer: That's
an excellent question,
and we get it all the time.
And we don't have
any doctors on staff.
So, he has a nonprofit again
located just outside of Boston.
That's not something
we can really get
into the medical evaluation.
So we really depend on the
government to help us out.
So we start, one of our initial
criterion for eligibility
for our program is actually
veteran must be eligible
for the veteran's administration
specially adapted housing grant.
And it's a program that is
Congressionally appropriated
as well as the eligibility
requirements are established
by the Congress.
So we're dependent on them to
actually evaluate the veterans
and determine the ones that
have the most severe injuries,
and these really fall into the
areas of loss or loss of use
of multiple limbs,
full partial paralysis,
and other things
along those lines
that they would then be
eligible for the SAH grant.
Then once they become
eligible for that,
then they can apply
to our program.
A lot of the veterans that
come to us aren't aware
of the SAH grant, and it's kind
of a daunting task to apply
and become eligible for it,
so we actually have a couple
wonderful ladies on staff
that know the system
extremely well,
have a wonderful working
relationship with the VA
and SAH program, and they will
walk them through the process
to where they can
become eligible for it.
And then once the veteran is
eligible, then they come to us
and get into our
application process.
We have an application.
We also do a couple
other vetting procedures.
We do a criminal
background check,
and we also do a
financial health check
over the last several years.
And because of the financial
planning and assistance
that I mentioned earlier
that's provided free of charge,
we decide whether we start
that early because some
of these guys, not
so much Steven here,
but some of these guys
are extremely young,
been injured early on their
life, and I don't know
about the former
[inaudible] of the Army,
but when I was a
young pup in the Army,
I did not have it all
together on my financial side.
So some of these
younger guys come to us,
and they've gone down range.
They've been paid
a lot of money.
It hasn't been taxed, and
they come back and do a lot
of different things with
it, buy a lot of toys
and different things,
and they're kind
of upside-down financial.
So we take a look at the
financial health of the veteran
and see whether or not we need
to start this financial planning
and assistance early or
we can start it later
when they get their home.
So we go through that, and
then the last thing we do is we
actually bring them up for
conference in Massachusetts.
I won't say it's the home
of a certain football team
because all my guys from
the staff will get excited
about that.
But we have a veterans
conference, normally two to four
of those every year, where
we bring in the new members
to our family and then start
working on finding their land
and building them a home.
I would say about
the SAH program
that just last week we had
a tremendous opportunity
to partner with a couple
of VSOs and the VA as well
and testified before, it
wasn't the house committee
on veterans affairs but
one of their subcommittees
on economic opportunity, on ways
to improve the SAH program as
and what we brought forward
as our recommendations
were actually accepted
by the subcommittee and the
VA as things that work and try
and get better, and we're after
blind veterans being included
into the SAH grant
program and veterans
who have lost their hands.
>> Karen Lloyd: Wow.
>> Tom Landwermeyer: Because
there's, the definitions
that they have for it, and the
members were actually asking the
VA rep is that something
that you can do
and make those changes or do
you need statutory authority,
and of course, the rep said,
no we got to have Congressional
authority, and they said,
well we're going
to get it for you.
So it was a great opportunity,
but again partnering both
with the VA and a
couple other VSOs.
>> Karen Lloyd: I
think it's great
that you're using what you're
learning from helping veterans
to make it even better,
make it a stronger program.
That's great.
Your organization has just
published some interesting
findings about how your
homes empower veterans
in their recovery.
Can you tell us about the impact
that your adapted homes have had
on the lives of veterans
and their families?
>> Tom Landwermeyer: Absolutely.
And for everybody that's in the
room, if you look to the seats
to either side, you've got
a little pamphlet that looks
like this, and everybody
watching,
we can certainly get them to you
in the members offices,
just let us know.
But I'd just like to hit a
couple things on the impact.
Our tag line is Building
Homes, Rebuilding Lives.
So building homes is really
the one thing that we do,
but rebuilding lives is
what's really important to us.
The building homes is
part of those numbers
that I was throwing out,
but those are just outputs.
What we're really after
measuring are the outcomes.
What's really happening to these
veterans and their families
when they go into these homes?
What are they accomplishing
afterwards?
So this document here,
when you take a look at it,
covers a bunch of those areas.
We did a, we've always
had, from our applications,
we've had the going in
information where they sit
in various areas like employment
and education and finances
and things like that,
but we didn't have the
after they've been in
the homes for a while.
So this past winter we
devised a survey that went back
out to our veterans
and the families.
We actually had a 64
percent response rate,
which gives us that, and we
know it's solid, and we looked
in the areas of, you know,
asked them about their freedom
and independence and rehabbing
in a safe environment.
We asked them about, again,
education, employment, family,
finances, all those
kinds of things,
and just to give you a couple
of them, over 90 percent
of our veterans responded
that they have now regained
the freedom and independence
in these homes that they had
lost with their injuries.
So that was really good for us.
On the education side,
before moving into our homes,
our veterans either had a
degree, were pursuing a degree,
or a trade certification,
only 12 percent of them.
After moving into our homes,
that shot up to 69 percent.
On the spouse and
caregiver side,
we really thought we
were having an impact.
We honestly knew in our gut
that we were having an impact
on the spouses and
caregivers because most
of them will tell you the story
that if they have
injured veterans,
wherever they're living, that
they sometimes don't even want
to leave the house
because they're worried
about their veteran falling,
they got really small
young children falling
and hurting themselves, the
child, so again, that's stress
and burden on the caregiver.
Well, on the education
side with the caregivers,
only eight percent
of them had a degree
or were pursuing
one before moving
into their homes,
afterwards 90 percent
>> Karen Lloyd: Wow.
>> Tom Landwermeyer: And
then, on the employment side,
is the only other one I'll point
out for you, and it gets back
to what Eric was talking about,
on the employment side
before moving into our homes
and then going into
them, our veterans ended
up with an employment
rate of 67 percent higher
after moving into the homes.
And on the spouse and caregiver
side, it was three times higher
than before they
moved into our homes.
So that's some of the
impacts, but thanks for asking.
>> Karen Lloyd: That's huge.
>> Tom Landwermeyer: It is.
>> Karen Lloyd: Well now we're
at where the rubber
meets the road.
Steve, Sam, the pressure
is on you.
Can you, can you tell us about
how the home that you received
from Home for Our Troops helps
you in your day-to-day life?
>> Steven Curry: Definitely.
So I'll kind of give
you a little bit
on background before
Homes for Our Troops.
Like I said, I was
injured in 2006,
lost my left leg below the knee.
My physical therapy
went pretty well.
My leg was amputated
December 1st.
In January sometime
I started-- oh no.
In March the next year I started
snowboarding, and then that kind
of became a new thing for me,
and it got to where
I could run again.
Everything was pretty normal.
So, when we left the hospital,
we moved into a two-story
townhouse,
never really had any
issues with that,
and after a few years we
decided to buy a house,
so we bought a two-story
house with a basement.
And that first summer
we were in the house,
I started having issues
with my residual limb.
Just a lot of leg pain.
I would get sores.
I was wearing my leg for
probably 16 hours a day.
So, it pretty much turned
into every summer I'd spend
about two months in my
wheelchair in the middle
of the summer just
letting my leg recuperate.
And it pretty much me out
of the action altogether
with the family.
I mean I could use my
wheelchair outside of the house
because our house just wasn't
conducive to using a wheelchair,
so my wheelchair stayed in
the garage or in my vehicle,
and I could get around work
and the stores pretty well,
but at home I'd use crutches,
and you can't really do a
whole lot with crutches.
Your hands are pretty occupied.
So I wasn't helping
out with the kids.
I wasn't helping out with
laundry or cooking or cleaning.
I pretty much just sat on the
couch, kind of angry with myself
for two months every year.
And at some point we started
looking for other options.
We found, actually Sam found
Homes for Our Troops and told me
to apply a couple times before
I finally went through with it.
And it's honestly, it's,
I couldn't imagine how much
better, you know, it could be.
I mean you think about
getting a free house,
that's pretty awesome
in and of itself.
But going from a two-story house
to a one-story house changed,
it changed things a lot for
me, just not having to go up
and down those stairs multiple
times every day, I think,
has taken a lot of
physical stress off my leg.
I don't have the issues
I used to have so often.
Anytime I do feel something
popping up, I can just hop
in my wheelchair and get around
the house, which alleviates,
you know, a small issue
turning into a large issue.
It's, it's made me also become
a more active participant
in our family, so I don't get
away with not doing laundry.
I don't get away
with not doing dishes
or helping out with the kids.
I mean there's really nowhere
in the house I can't get to,
even if I'm in my wheelchair,
including outside the house.
So, you know, even if I'm
stuck in my wheelchair,
I'm still taking out the trash.
[laughter] So, you know, for me
mentally it's helped out a lot
because I don't have to
get stuck in a situation
where I can't participate.
It helps me and Sam out, you
know, because if I'm grumpy,
she's grumpy, and we're,
you know, it's kind of just,
there's a lot of friction there.
I'm sure our kids saw that.
So that alleviated that, and
then, you know, I won't speak
for Sam, but I'm sure
it alleviated a lot
of stress on her part as well.
>> Karen Lloyd: Okay.
Sam, what are your thoughts?
How has it helped?
>> Samantha Curry: It's been
honestly pretty amazing.
I think one of, there's
two stories that we think
about when we lived in the three
story house with a basement.
One, I remember coming home
one day and he was hopping
down the stairs with
our infant in his arms
and should not have
been doing that.
He eventually scooted
on his bottom,
but still, it wasn't safe.
And living at the other house,
he would always in the middle
of the night would just
hop and go straight to the,
like to go to the restroom
if he needed to go.
And at the new house,
that doesn't happen.
I mean there's no stairs.
I hear him in the middle of
the night putting his leg on
and like actually walking.
We don't have little
kids anymore, so that's,
he doesn't have to carry
them, even though they still
like to be carried sometimes.
But if definitely has
relieved a lot of stress.
I feel like we communicate
better because we're not
so stressed about
anything in regards
to doing things around
the house.
I feel like he lives
a more free life.
Like, he loves going outside
and working in the yard.
We have chickens and a garden,
and he loves doing that,
so I feel like there's freedom
for him to do that now too.
He'll even go jump on
the trampoline with girls
and do backflips, which
I think if we still lived
at the old house in the
summertime that wouldn't happen
because those probably
five to seven summers
that it did happen
were very stressful.
He wouldn't play with the
girls just because he couldn't.
It's not like he didn't want to.
He just, he couldn't do it.
And you could tell, like it
was devastating for them,
and they love how active he is
now even though we're definitely
not on the younger side anymore.
>> Karen Lloyd: It's so fun
to watch your interaction.
It's so cool.
>> Samantha Curry: Yeah.
>> Karen Lloyd: Steve
mentioned about caregivers,
and you're a caregiver.
Could you expound upon
what that's been like
and how you've reached out to
other caregivers or they reached
out to you and if that's made
a difference and if so, how.
>> Samantha Curry: Definitely.
I will say he's made
my job pretty easy
in the caregiver aspect.
Right after the injury,
he was always lighthearted
about the situation, which
I think helped while we were
at the hospital.
Once leaving the hospital, you
know, things definitely changed,
because I wasn't around, you
know, other wives or spouses
who were at the hospital
that I could talk
to on a regular basis.
So the first couple years
it was definitely rough.
I didn't really speak to many
wives my age who were going
through the same thing.
And then probably about
seven years ago, I met a lady
who was kind of a part of an
organization, Hearts of Valor,
for caregivers, and we
connected with a group
that was in our local area.
So we would have like group
meetings once a month,
which was fantastic.
It was nice to really talk to
others about the situation,
because they understood, they
knew kind of what I was feeling,
and they understood that even
though I loved my husband,
there were things that other
people just wouldn't understand.
So that was really nice.
And I've been connected with
her for the last seven years.
We've been lucky enough
too to find friends
who were previous military,
and while their spouse
isn't injured,
they have that military
connection,
so I can definitely talk
to them about some things,
because I think it's always
good to talk to people who kind
of understand your background.
But it's also nice to have
friends who still want to learn
and understand the stresses that
we do have on a daily basis,
because it's not just the leg.
I mean we have memory
issues, so we have, you know,
a family calendar, that
was an idea given to us
that we've been able to
use to help with that.
So it's nice to have people
to really just talk
to on that basis.
>> Karen Lloyd: Awesome.
Great news.
Jason, as an advisor to the
Veterans Affairs secretary,
you have no doubt observed both
the successes and limitations
of what VA can provide.
Are there some ways outside
organizations can partner
with VA to improve
the care for veterans.
>> Jason Beardsley: Absolutely.
Such a good question and
what a humbling answer
to listen to your story.
And then what I'll say,
particularly to that is Steve,
you mentioned the great work the
Elizabeth Dole Foundation has
done, and the secretary last
week announced our Center
for Excellence, which based on
family and veteran caregivers,
and this Center of Excellence is
going to allow the VA to study
across it's network and academic
facilities what we're doing
well, where we need
to strengthen,
where we've learned lessons
from other organizations.
And so the focus
of the secretary is now
how do we do this best.
And it's all because
organizations
like Elizabeth Dole Foundation
have been applying energies
in that direction
for a long time.
So I'm really glad
to see, number one,
that that's something that
we've announced as recently
as last week, I think
September 7th.
So, other ways, everybody else
here on the board has kind
of weighed in, I think
the hiring of troops,
the building of homes.
I'm the Veteran Service
Organization liaison.
It's a huge role.
It's a huge community,
and what we look for,
the VA is the second largest
department in the government,
something like 340 or
50 thousand employees.
We service about 9
million veterans.
As you can see with our
facilities, we have a gap.
I call it kind of
that last mile.
I'm a veteran myself,
and when I came home,
I didn't have any means,
I didn't know anybody,
there was really not the same
need for me to approach the VA.
So, one of the first things
I think people can do is what
you've done here, Sam,
which is you've got to turn
to the people you know the
ones that you trust and care
and be able to kind of kick
them in the gut a little.
I think most of us in the
Army or service members
that have gone through
some of those experiences,
we're probably the last
ones to raise our hand
and say, I need a little help.
Am I right?
>> Steven Curry: Yes, correct.
>> Jason Beardsley:
So for those people
who know a veteran who's had
some of these experiences,
it starts with the community.
And this is where
the VA really relies
on those service organizations
to know our community members,
our service members, and
know what they're missing
so that someone can
actually put them in touch
with the right type
of organization
that can actually
facilitate their benefits.
I think somebody else mentioned
how daunting the task can be
because there are, you know,
three different administrations
from health to benefits
to national cemetery,
and they each handle a
number of different things
that a veteran might go
through in their life.
So we have essentially a
large conglomerate of services
that are very difficult
to navigate
if you haven't had the
experience with it.
And so, we rely on organizations
that have a particular cause
or an interest, such as
Elizabeth Dole Foundation
with caregivers, and when
they have that interest,
that passion, if you can find
them and link up with them,
they're typically
subject matter experts.
They're hand in hand with us,
creating legislation and policy,
staffing working
groups to ensure
that the policies
actually are met
and then executed in the field.
There are so many things
happening in the department
at any one time that it's
overwhelming to start fresh
and not know where to go.
So you really need someone
that can help you navigate
or sherpa you through
our institution.
And that's where the veteran
service organizations couldn't
be any better.
We have a tremendous
amount of them out there.
They're very, there's
a very large population
of military service
organizations
and veteran service
organizations.
We maintain a website that lists
those that we've recognized,
and then there are plenty
that are not yet recognized
but still doing good
work on a local level.
And so if you can find
those first, you're going
to find folks that are really
passionate about a cause,
and once you find those folks,
it's a lot easier for them
to help you access the
services and systems you need.
Now, in our defense, we're
trying to make that easier,
but in the second
largest government agency,
that is not an easy thing.
This year we've been very happy
with the work that Congress
and the previous President and
this President have engaged
in to pass some major
legislation.
I think Secretary
Wilke has famously said
that we've had more change now
on the books by statute and law
than the Veterans
Administration has seen
since really it's
inception or really
under Omar Bradley
in World War II.
So we're experiencing some very
new things, and the future is,
I think, very bright for us.
We have to be cautiously
optimistic
because when we do well, we
get a story like you've told,
but that's a combination,
a joint partnership here,
and when we don't
find those gaps,
then we have the opposite story,
and we need to mitigate those
to the extent possible.
So, very much relying
on our partnerships.
>> Karen Lloyd: Well,
you've mentioned briefly
that there's some
pending legislation also
new VA services.
Would this be a good
opportunity for you to kind
of do a quick commercial
for either of those--
>> Jason Beardsley: Absolutely.
>> Karen Lloyd: For
this audience.
>> Jason Beardsley:
Yeah, I'll try to make it
as boring as possible.
Not, very excited,
the VA Mission Act
that just got passed is one
of the most expansive acts.
It's appropriated $5.2 billion.
Part of that too is
expanding on caregivers.
So we recently, or legacy
caregivers were only post 9/11,
so we've now rolled that back to
those who have been giving care
to veterans from the Vietnam
era and the Gulf War era.
And it's a recognition
on the VA's part
that we did have a gap
in the environment.
I think you mentioned,
Steve, that the study
that Rand did told us
about what's happening
with our veterans, our
younger population,
how we're bringing them home,
and then how we can
actually care for them
in their homes rather
than facility.
So part of the VA Mission
Act will help close the loop
on that.
In addition, there are so
many other good parts to it,
but electronic health care
modernization, this is an effort
for the VA to do what I
think is a common sense,
modern technology thing, right,
by allowing the service member
to step into the, you
know, once you swear in,
you have a service record, and
that record will be electronic
and will carry with you
for the life of you,
including when you leave your
service and enter the arms
of the Department of the VA.
Right now that's a legacy
system we're dealing
with that has great features
to it, but it was built 20
and 30 years ago, so we're
now at the phase where we're
about to initiate
a change in that,
which will hopefully
facilitate a lot more care
with a lot more speed
if you will now.
The veteran who has his
record, carries it with him,
and then can share that
out whether it's internal
to our community or
as importantly now,
especially with the
VA Mission Act,
external to our community
care partners.
And that's another
component of the Mission Act,
which is we found that
where the VA does well is
when you get in the door.
It's when you can't get in that
we have to service our veterans.
So allowing veterans
to choose their care
in the community has been a
vital piece, and that's going
to happen with this as well.
Plenty of other stuff, but
in the interest of time,
I'll leave it there for now.
>> Karen Lloyd: Wow,
thank you so much.
I would ask each panelist
if they would care
to share a one minute
commercial if you will
of what you want folks to
have gotten from this panel.
So, Eric.
>> Eric Eversole: Thank you.
And I'll keep it at one minute.
You know, I think we've talked
about this a couple of times,
and it's certainly something my
organization has really started
to realize and has been
realizing the last couple years
as we talked about, military
spouses and caregivers,
you know, from our
organization's perspective
and as we continue to
serve those who serve,
we look at service a little more
expansively than just the person
who puts on the uniform.
I think if there's a gap between
the civilian military divide,
I think there's a chasm
between what our country knows
about military spouses and
caregivers and the service
and the sacrifice
that they made.
As we get into September
11th tomorrow and closer
to Veterans' Day, you know, I'd
ask those in this room and those
on the webinar to really
think about military spouses
and caregivers from the vantage
point that they served too.
They've served and sacrificed
for our country, and as we think
about how we can meet their
needs, we need to think
about the entire
family that serves
around that service member.
>> Karen Lloyd: Thank you, Eric.
Steve.
>> Steven Schwab:
I'll just say ditto.
Eric put it really well.
I guess I'd remind everybody
in the room and those watching
that less than one-half
of one percent
of our country is defending our
freedom in the armed services,
which means there's
99 percent of us
who don't really understand
what happens inside
of military families
and the challenges
that have been discussed up here
and that are happening
every day.
And so I'd like to
remind everybody
that our job really is
only just beginning.
The veterans who are
continuing to come home
from the longest period of war
in U.S. history are bringing
complex needs and issues
to the home front, and they
have a family and community
around them that need to
be embraced and supported.
And it's up to all of us
to ask what we can do.
So inside of our
employers and our churches,
our community organizations
and our neighborhoods,
seek out your military
family neighbors.
They're, Sam and Steven would
probably say they're reluctant
to ask for help.
But if you find them and you
offer, usually they'll take you
up on it, and sometimes
it's the simple things.
We know, for instance, most of
our families just need a break.
Babysitter, cut the lawn,
help with the groceries,
those sorts of things.
But it's really up to each of
us to seek out those neighbors,
friends, family members, and
see what we can do to help them.
>> Karen Lloyd: That's awesome.
And that really falls in
line with what we believe
at the Veterans History Project,
which is listen, really listen
to the veteran in your life and
let them know you are listening.
Tom.
>> Tom Landwermeyer:
Thanks Karen.
For everybody here
and tuning in,
the first thing I'd do is
challenge every single person
to just reach out and touch five
people and help with awareness
on what you heard about today,
the organizations
you heard about.
Go ahead and check us all out.
And then specifically
for us, we've got 1000
to 1200 more veterans like
Steven and caregivers like Sam
that still are in need
and really deserve
these kind of homes.
So we've got a lot
of work to do.
The second thing I'd say
for the staffers and members
that may have tuned in or
will tune in and watch this
over in the coming days, is we
discussed some of those things
with the SEH program,
the grant program,
that needs some changing
to bring some work,
we're leaving some
veterans behind
in that program right now.
So I would ask them to go
back and support the efforts
of the subcommittee on economic
opportunity as they move forward
with that with the VA.
And then last, I would also
say for both my cohorts here
in other charities, both
mentioned about, you know,
volunteering, helping
out, and you don't have
to wear a uniform to be serving.
All charities out there,
all of us need volunteers.
We won't succeed
without our volunteers.
So get online, check us
out, and get out there
and help these veterans.
Thanks.
>> Karen Lloyd: Well said.
Steve.
>> Steven Curry: I'll hit on
a little bit of what Tom said.
The road to recovery for service
members like myself really,
is really built on a combination
of organizations like the VA
and all of the different
veteran service organizations.
So, if you know of a
program that the VA offers
or veteran service out there
that could help out a veteran
that you know or in
you family, it really,
it's a really good idea to
given them a push, you know,
give them a kick in the
rear to go and reach
out to those organizations.
Because like I said before, I
would not have applied to Homes
for Our Troops or I wouldn't
have applied for the SAH grant
if Sam hadn't have kind of--
>> Samantha Curry: Pestered you?
>> Steven Curry: Yeah, guided
me in that direction multiple,
you know, over a
long period of time.
And, you know, really
I would have been,
I would have been missing out,
and I've talked to veterans
who have that mindset where,
you know, I'll let the guys
that need it most
access that care,
and while that's an admirable
thing to think and feel,
you really should leave it up
to the organizations to decide
who needs that care the most.
And on top of that,
like Tom said, you know,
look at those veteran service
organizations, do your research,
and know, you know, who the good
ones are and donate, you know,
your time and your
money and your resources
to help these organizations
out so they can help out,
you know, guys like myself.
>> Karen Lloyd: Thanks Steve.
Sam, thank you for
all that you've done
and your support of Steve.
It's great to hear that you're
behind making a difference.
>> Samantha Curry: Definitely.
Thank you.
>> Karen Lloyd: And
your thoughts?
>> Samantha Curry: I
would definitely just say
to any caregiver out there
find somebody who can be there
to support you if you need it.
Or maybe if you know a caregiver
and maybe you're not one
but you know one, always just
ask them how they're doing,
do they need something.
They'll probably be
like me and say no,
but I think that
they'll understand
that somebody is still there
and someone still cares
and is asking how
they're doing for sure.
>> Karen Lloyd: If somebody
asks you what you needed
and your tendency is to say no,
what's the one thing they could
do that would brighten your day?
>> Samantha Curry: I
think really for me is,
I think just them asking,
even though I say no,
just that they will ask,
initiate and ask a question,
or even if it's just
asking how are you doing
or how's the family, I think
just asking for me is much more
than anything than not asking.
I think that even goes with
saying like an injured veteran,
you know, don't just
stare at them.
Most of them will be willing to
talk about it, even if it's just
like I'm okay, but just ask.
Definitely just always ask.
>> Karen Lloyd: That's really
good advice, thank you.
Jason.
>> Jason Beardsley:
Yeah, thank you.
These have been incredible
comments, and so, you know,
I have to commend the panel.
I think it's been said, and
I'll emphasize it, you know,
we don't serve as
single members.
We serve as families and
really as communities
because when we put service
members in war or in conflict,
we do that as a community.
So knowing that, when
the service members leave
and come back to
reintegrate in society,
they can only be
reintegrated also
by community, family, and peers.
And it's been said a bunch
of times, but if you're
out there listening, again, I'll
just say, like Steve, myself,
and the peers that I served
with, those in harm's way,
they're mission focused and
they're mission oriented,
and they're typically the
last ones to say, you know,
pay attention to me
or give me the care.
So we do rely on our spouses
and those who are our peers
to kick us in the gut a
little bit and get us moving.
So if you know folks like that,
just know there's an
initial resistance.
But at the other end,
in the community,
are these tremendous
organizations, businesses,
charities, VSOs, MSOs,
that are ready to support.
And right behind that
is your government.
We brought you into service,
we're going to continue
to care for you.
Sometimes it's a little
difficult figuring out the path
or navigating that path,
but that's what we're
all up here for.
You're not there alone.
So if anybody hears this message
out there and feels that way,
it's time for them to kind
of tap out and say, hey,
I need a hand, and you've
got plenty of people ready
to help you, and at the end
of that, the organizations,
the Veterans Affairs
Department, are all here
to support our veterans.
So, make sure if you do know
someone, ask the question,
and then follow up and
get them into the hands
of that next level of care.
>> Karen Lloyd: Wow, that
was so really well said.
I think what the folks that
are here today and also those
that are listening have
heard about today is
about rebuilding lives and
also that it really is an arc
of a story, and I think we've
heard that there is lots
of people involved with that.
Everything from the government
to nonprofit organizations
to the folks that are living the
life, and I want to thank all
of you for coming today
and being a part of this.
Right before we end, I'd like
to bring up Patty Calatano
and also Tom, if you would.
They have been kind enough.
They are going to make a
donation of some veteran stories
to the Library's
Veterans History Project.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Tom Landwermeyer: So, first
off, we got to thank Karen
and Veteran History Project
and the Library of Congress
for putting this on today.
And also, thank you for your own
personal dedication and service
to our country over
time and for what you
and your outfit are doing
every day to keep veterans
and families in the
forefront of America.
We really appreciate.
So what we've got for you
today are four recordings
from our [inaudible] veterans
as entries, permanent entries
into the Veteran History
Project, and we really do hope
in some way they help further
the cause and the mission of,
you know, educating the American
public on both their services
and their sacrifice on behalf
of those freedoms that,
you know, we enjoy every day.
>> Karen Lloyd: Well, Tom, on
behalf of a grateful nation--
>> Tom Landwermeyer: Thank you.
>> Karen Lloyd: I want to
thank you for that [inaudible].
>> Tom Landwermeyer: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> Karen Lloyd: You're welcome.
>> Tom Landwermeyer:
Thank you, Karen.
>> Karen Lloyd: And I
would also like be remiss
if I didn't thank the staff of
the Veterans History Project,
specifically Andrew Huber
for making a difference
and the staff from
across the Library
that made this all possible.
So thank you all so very
much and again, panelists,
they for coming today.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.